Iain: There are an enormous number of aspects
of modernist culture, the culture of the last
hundred years or so, which simulates schizophrenia.
Brent: Well, it's my pleasure to welcome Dr.
Iain McGilchrist, psychiatrist and author
of "The Master and His Emissary: The Divided
Brain and the Making of the Western World"
here to AEI.
Dr. McGilchrist holds multiple fellowships
at Oxford University, the Royal College of
Psychiatrists, and the Royal Society of Arts.
So, welcome, Iain.
It's good to have you.
Iain: Thank you very much, Brent.
Brent: So, I hear from others that one question
authors don't usually get asked when they
come on to a program like this is, what's
your book about?
So, why don't you start there and give us
a little bit of what your book is about?
Iain: Well, it's about the vexed topic
of the difference between the brain hemispheres,
a topic that has become rather toxic topic
because of its exploitation by media people
and pop psychology.
And it started with things that we learnt...well,
it took off, let me say, because we learned
differences about the brain hemispheres in
the 19th century, but it really took off after
the first split-brain operations in Caltech
in the 1960s where the brain was divided,
this was for treatment of intractable epilepsy,
and it gave people an insight into what the
two halves of the brain might do that were
different.
And, out of that came a number of ideas that
eventually were proved to be wrong.
They were, for example, that the left hemisphere
does language and reason and the right hemisphere
does emotion and pictures.
And, with further research, it was found that,
in fact, both hemispheres were involved with
everything, but that was the bit that we didn't
notice, was that they were involved consistently
in two entirely different ways.
And, the subject had fallen into disrepute
because we were only asking the machine question,
what does it do?
And finding that they're both involved in
doing everything.
But, the question...the more human question,
and, after all, the brain is part of a person,
"In what way do they do?"
Was not being asked, but if you ask that question,
you get a fascinating series of answers.
And, my book is really expounding what those
differences are between the two brain hemispheres,
and what inference that might have on the
history of culture, including, and specifically,
our own culture now.
Brent: You talk about the right hemisphere
of the brain as being the master...
Iain: Yes.
Brent: ...and you talk about the left hemisphere
as being the emissary.
Iain: Yes.
Brent: Tell us what you mean by that.
Iain: Well, the image comes from a story of
a wise spiritual master who looked after a
community so well that it flourished and grew,
and after a while he discovered that he not
only couldn't look after everything that was
needed by these people, this community, but
that importantly he couldn't be involved in
certain things if he was to maintain his overview.
So, he delegated that job of going about and
doing certain quite specific detailed, administrative
tasks to his brightest and best servant.
The trouble with this guy was that he was
bright, but not bright enough to know what
it was he didn't know, and so he thought,
"I know everything.
What does the master know?
He doesn't know anything.
He's sitting back there smiling seraphically
back at base.
He doesn't know anything.
I'm the one that does all the heavy lifting.
I really understand."
The trouble is he didn't know what it was
he didn't know.
He didn't know what it was the master knew.
The master knew he needed the emissary.
The emissary didn't know he needed the master.
And this led to the collapse of the community,
and this is a parable.
The parable, I think, applies to the relationship
between the two neuronal systems, the two
hemispheres.
One has a broad view, which includes the need
for a detailed view.
It has a global view that sees the need for
certain quite specific facts and data.
The other hemisphere, and this is the left
hemisphere, sees only the details, but has
no concept that it's missing the big picture.
It thinks that maybe you can put all these
details together and they'll compose the big
picture, but actually it's not like that.
We think, and the left hemisphere can't see
that it could be otherwise, that a whole is
simply made by putting together the parts.
But, actually, the whole of many things, as
we appreciate in living, is not the same as
what you get when you take it apart into a
handful of pieces.
Brent: And so, you've used some interesting
examples in the past about this from the animal
kingdom...
Iain: Yes.
Brent: ...and how you sort of...how the penny
dropped as it were when you started studying
animal behavior.
Could you talk a little bit about that, because
that helps to explain this left-right hemisphere
distinction?
Iain: Yes.
Well, it's not just human beings that have
lateralized brains, in other words, that have
two halves of the brain that are not symmetrical.
By the way, they're not symmetrical in anything
you can measure, anatomically or physiologically.
So, functionally, structurally, they are different,
reliably so.
But this is not just about humans.
This is not even about apes.
It's not even about mammals, or reptiles,
or amphibians, or fish, or insects, or nematode
worms.
Every existing living thing that we know that
has any kind of neuronal structure at all
has an asymmetrical one, and that leads to
the question, "Why?"
And there is an answer to this, which gradually
dawned on me, which is that it has an important
evolutionary significance, that is that it
solves a conundrum, how to eat and stay alive,
and that doesn't sound like a conundrum to
us now, but for most animals, it's a dangerous
business being focused on one thing because
you're obviously not looking at everything
else.
So, while you're focusing on catching that
rabbit, picking out that seed against the
background of grit, you know, picking up a
twig to build the nest, you've got to have
very sharply focused attention, just very
narrow view attention to a detail.
But if that's the only attention you're paying,
you'll soon become somebody else's lunch while
you're getting your own, because you need
to have a sustained vigilance for predators,
for conspecifics, for others that are around,
and for everything else basically that is
going on in the world.
And, when you observe animals and bird, what
you find is that the left hemisphere serves
the predator instinct in which you go for
some detail, and therefore is good for manipulating
the world.
But it's not terribly clever, it doesn't really
see the whole picture, it doesn't understand
what it's doing, but it's a servant, it's
a very good servant.
The right hemisphere, meanwhile, is understanding
the whole thing and saying, "I see where this
thing of getting my lunch and getting that
twig for the...how that fits into the whole."
And, what I am suggesting is that in the way
in which we now think, we've got locked on
to a rather unintelligent way of thinking
that enables you to be very efficient at grasping,
but not very efficient at understanding.
And you think about it, the left hemisphere
is the part of your brain that controls your
right hand, which is the one with which you
do all the grasping, and it's the one that
controls the bits of language, not all of
language, but the bits that enable you to
say, "Oh, I've grasped it."
In other words, you've got some little certain
factoid, but the problem is you try to live
a wise life on the basis of putting a lot
of these together, and you simply can't.
Brent: You've covered pretty well for us the
scientific side of this, but that's only half
of your book.
The second half of your book is really devoted
to an analysis, a cultural analysis, historical
analysis, and I'd like you to unpack that
a little bit, you know, in terms of what you
think your research tells us about the development
of the West, Western civilization.
Iain: The trigger for this came from a book
by a distinguished colleague called Louis
Sass who wrote a book called "Madness and
Modernism," and effectively what that book
demonstrated was that there are an enormous
number of aspects of modernist culture, the
culture of the last hundred years or so, which
simulates schizophrenia.
In other words, people who suffer from schizophrenia
describe experiences, depict phenomena that
are extraordinary like those that are in the
mainstream of modernism.
Now, that was a...and, over 500 pages, he
shows this time and time again in great detail.
It's very convincing.
For example, many of the movements in the
visual arts in the last hundred years exemplify
various phenomena of distorted vision which
are found in people with right hemisphere
damage.
So, some of the actual movements that became
popular exemplified phenomena that until now
have been quite peculiar to people with schizophrenia.
And, you see it also in, for example, the
literature where a deliberate effect of sense
of alienation that perhaps other people are
machines are not really living, but they're
almost like sort of terrifying zombies, or
the sense that you yourself are cut off and
unable to feel for anything, and the distortion
of perspective, the deliberate disruption
of narrative which has been part of the way
in which novels have been written at periods
during the last hundred years, and the willingness
to strip things away from context and deliberately
make them seem strange or odd creates an effect
which is awfully like the experiences that
people with schizophrenia describe.
They seem to be experiencing something that
modernist artists, writers, and even philosophers
seem to be tackling, which is this kind of
devitalization, this alienation, this disembodiment,
this mechanization, and so forth, which comes
out in the art and culture.
So, question is, "Why?"
And this struck me like a thunderbolt because
I've been researching at Johns Hopkins in
Baltimore on asymmetries in the brain of people
with schizophrenia, and what I had learned,
amongst many other things, apart from the
fact that their brains are not asymmetrical
in the way that ours are, is that people with
schizophrenia are awfully like people with
right-hemisphere brain damage.
People with right-hemisphere strokes, or tumors,
or injuries experience things, describe things,
depict things in the way that people with
schizophrenia do, broadly.
I mean, there are differences, but that's
a very substantial similarity.
And so, what I took from this was that it
wasn't that we were all becoming schizophrenic,
but that maybe we were not utilizing what
our right hemispheres tell us.
We were listening only to what our left hemispheres
tell us.
And, I looked at that for quite a long time
and saw masses of evidence that this seemed
to hold up, and I then thought, well, if that's
the case, and in the past we've had, you know,
different kinds of culture, I mean, many movements
in the history of ideas in the West, they
presumably weren't at all so skewed in this
way.
And I looked at the ancient Greek civilization,
at the Roman civilization, and our own modern
civilization, starting with the Renaissance
and moving forwards through big movements
like the Reformation, the Enlightenment, romanticism,
modernism, and post-modernism, and to abbreviate
a much longer story, effectively what I saw
there was the same shape repeated.
And that shape goes like this, at the beginning
of a civilization, it seems suddenly to erupt
with a great efflorescence of ideas, thoughts,
creative material in poetry, in drama, in
history-making, in the writing of myths, in
the exploration of the seas, the stars, the
use of mathematics, even the beginnings of
engineering, and these things then, over time,
which are so effective and so flourishing,
quite soon, over a period of usually about
400 or 500 years, deteriorate in a recognizable
way.
The society becomes more rigid, it becomes
more steeply hierarchical, it becomes more
bureaucratic, it becomes more interested in
control and power than it is in actually imagination,
which requires that you make yourself vulnerable
in certain ways, and it simply can't afford
to do this.
And the Greeks overreached themselves with
their civilization, the Romans did the same,
and they collapsed.
Now, in our own case, I believe that we're
following the same path, that we were very
rich in creativity for a few hundred years,
and that in the last...certainly, particularly
the last 150 years, there has been an overemphasis
on domination, getting empire, first, notably
the British and then more in a commercial
sense, the Americans, and cultural domination,
in which I think a very diminished sort of
bureaucratic...necessarily so because when
you've got an empire, you know, what are you
gonna do?
You're going to be emphasizing the military,
and the bureaucracy, and the administration...
Brent: It has to be managed.
Iain: It has to be managed.
And so, management think, which to me is the
death of imagination, becomes, if you like,
the way in which everything is interpreted.
It's interpreted as essentially knowable,
quantitative, objective, and essentially dead,
whereas, in fact, everything we experience
is changing, animate, and multiply connected
to everything else we know.
So, one living animate, changing... pleasantly,
constantly leading one beyond the horizons
of what one knows now, that kind of a world
gets eliminated in favor of a dead, static,
contained, knowable nothing.
That's where we're at.
Brent: Well, that's a little daunting.
So, tell me how you see...just to build on
that a bit, for the average person who's thinking
about what you're saying, what would you point
to as evidence of this overworking, I guess,
of the left hemisphere in our society around
us?
How does it manifest itself?
Iain: Well, I don't know what it's like in
America, but if you try dealing with any administrative
body, even with your bank or the telephone
company, you find yourself pushed down an
algorithm that doesn't have anything to do
with your circumstances.
And it's over-control, people who are not,
as it were, trained or educated to the point
where they can think for themselves are dealing
with this as a new situation.
Instead, they have a repertoire of stale abstractive
situations which they are told to handle in
certain predicted ways.
And, unfortunately, life is never like that,
and almost never can be solved in that way.
I mean, its problems can't be solved in that
way.
So, this is something that I imagine we all
have experience of.
Also, our educational system has in my lifetime
gone from being something which encouraged
free thinking...in fact, the purpose of it
was to encourage people to think differently,
to question...whatever the received thinking
of the age, also to learn hard a lot of the
things about the past, which would help you
to interpret the present and give a context
to it.
Nowadays people are not interested in, and
don't learn about the past.
They're over-technically educated, and under-humanistically
educated.
They don't actually know much about history,
which is, after all, the sum of human experience
so far.
They're not encouraged to examine imaginatively
literature which enables you to get into other
worlds than the one we now live in.
I mean, the whole point of education is not
to be relevant.
The worst possible thing is say it must be
relevant.
What that means is it's got to replicate whatever
it is we're stuck in now.
But the point of education is to break out
of what we're stuck in now.
And so, that's the error.
And, if you now...I mean, I used to teach
literature, and one of the marvelous things
about it...it was great literatures, absolutely
unique, impossible to rephrase as a bunch
of ideas.
It just has a powerful effect on you as an
embodied being, you know.
And then, now, I mean, I have a daughter who
studied English, and, I mean, what she studied
was, first of all, very little of what I would
call the canon, which is now considered to
be somehow irrelevant, but actually without
it you can't understand where we are now.
If you don't understand history, you don't
understand where you are, like trying to abstract
yourself from space and say, "Where am I?"
And you delete all the places around, you
don't know where you are or what you're doing.
So, that happened, and then, of course, the
attitude is to be superior to the work, because
you now have information at a point of view
that this poor sucker who wrote this play
or novel in the past didn't have.
So, we now tick him off, "Oh, he was a racist,
and a sexist, and a...whatever," and we never
actually make contact with the thing as a
living thing that is speaking to us imaginatively.
I mean, this is terrible.
Brent: So, I mean, I think all of us have
been...all of us have, you know, deep concerns
about the nature of public discourse today,
you know, the lack of empathy, the lack of
imagination, and creativity, and problem-solving,
and things like that.
Do you think that's a function of this phenomenon?
Iain: Well, I think, with phenomenon, if I'm
right, we are trained to disattend to things
that are not explicit and that are not in
the foreground, and actually all the interest
is going on in the background, the context,
the implicit.
If I'm right, and we're mainly focused on
grabbing the obvious, then we would be living
in a materialist society that didn't value
spiritual things which simply can't be measured
and can't be proved.
It would tend to prefer technical matters
that can be measured to those that are creative.
It would tend to stultify the insulate.
And I think that is what is happening, and
people aren't trained to think critically
about their own opinions, so you get...
You know, when I was at school I was taught
the purpose of an education is to be able
to give graded consent or graded descent to
any proposition, and I believe there is nothing
so good that more and more, and more of it
is just better, and there is nothing so bad
the little bit of it might not do some good.
And, if you accept that, and I think it's
hard not to, then the discussion has to be
about where we should position ourselves on
this continue.
That is not had as a discussion because people
are polarized.
The left hemisphere tends to be extremely
crude, and black and white, and sets up oppositions.
The right hemisphere is better at seeing that
things that look like opposites may cohere.
They may actually need one another and coexist.
But I'd like to say that one of the most important
things in which our younger people can see
the fruits of this way of thinking are all
around us in what we know about the destruction
of the natural world, the destruction of species,
the poisoning of the seas, the deforestation
of the earth, in the tendency to grab resources
at the expense of, say, whole indigenous peoples
that get wiped out, and the over-control of
all lives through monitoring of every kind:
DNA databases, CCTV cameras, monitoring your
online movements, and so forth.
And this has become a totalitarian nightmare
already in China, and I worry about this being
exported here.
There are already science that it is actually
happening here.
Brent: It is happening here, but it's interesting
because it's coming through the private sector
rather than the government.
Iain: Yeah.
No.
That's right.
Completely, yeah.
Can I talk about Predictim?
Brent: Yes, please.
Go right ahead.
Iain: Do you know about Predictim?
Brent: No, please.
Tell us about it.
Iain: Okay.
Well, you know, in China they have this Social
Credit System whereby everything you do is
monitored and evaluated, and if you talk to
the wrong person, or voice the wrong opinion,
or buy the wrong thing at a store, this counts
against you.
And if you get enough black points...bad points,
you can't actually get a job, or take a loan,
or even move from your town because you can't
buy a train ticket.
Well, believe it or not, in America there
is a private company called Predictim that
has developed an algorithm, and these things
always start as for your own protection, you
know, how everything sinister gets in, to
make things safer.
And this one is about, how can you get safer
than this babysitting?
Oh, that really speaks to the core because
everybody wants to protect their child.
So, there is an algorithm, it will tell you
whether a babysitter is reliable.
And, how does it do that?
It monitors your Facebook page, and your Instagram
posts, and everything that they can find out
about the websites that you visit, and it
looks at your face and your facial expressions
and movements, and records your opinions,
and it can tell the difference between a funny
remark, a sarcastic remark, or a mark out
of context ,or anything else, and it creates
a score, a mindless score that even the people
who created it don't know where it gets the
data from, and you, the victim of this, don't
know why you're getting a bad score.
And, that would perhaps not matter very much
if it only happened if you were babysitting,
but now companies are using Predictim data
to hire people.
So, if you've got, like you voiced an opinion
that was controversial, you're marked down
as a troublemaker.
But the society needs people who are going
to be a little bit rebellious.
Brent: Right.
Wow.
Okay.
So, let's wrap up on this question.
If, as you say, this problem of left hemisphere
dominance has occurred in the past, why should
we worry about it?
You know, won't it just correct itself over
time the way it has in the past?
Iain: Well, the last time civilization collapsed
in the West, it took a thousand years for
one to re-emerge, so that would be concerning,
but not very.
But, the thing is that in the late Roman Empire,
they were able to commit suicide as a civilization,
but they weren't able actually physically
to destroy the means of life.
But, we now have accelerating power, logarithmically
accelerating power, and technology is a wonderful
thing if you're wise enough to know how to
use it.
But every technology can be used for good
or ill, and it's only a matter of time before
that immense power falls into the hands of
people whose desires are not good, not ones
we would appreciate.
And so, at the same time that society faces
the possibility of a totalitarian regime,
quite quickly amassing an enormous amount
of data such that, you know, it just dwarfs
anything the Soviet system ever thought of,
that can happen.
It can happen in the West.
People say it couldn't happen here.
That's nonsense.
Democracy is a fragile flower, and it can
easily be trampled on.
And, you know, we saw totalitarian regimes
arise in places like Germany and Italy in
the last century, places with a long civilized
history.
So, that can happen.
And, the other thing that I'm talking about,
which seems to me the most serious thing of
all, is that I think there is good evidence
that climate change has now got to the point
where it is irreversible, and the consequences
of this mean that there will be changes in
the way in which people can inhabit certain
parts of the world.
In other words, there'll be mass migrations
of populations away from areas of drought
and famine, and these will be so large that
they can't be policed or resisted, and there
will be a breakdown in civil order.
Now, if that happens, this civilization will
end.
And it may be not just a matter of a thousand
years, but if the planet is properly despoiled,
it may be much, much longer.
The planet will survive.
People say, "Let's save the planet."
I would say the planet is amazingly resilient.
The planet has been through many, many things.
It's human beings that are fragile, and the
planet will survive, but we won't be there
to see it.
And I happen to think that's a great shame.
Brent: Dr. McGilchrist, it's been a pleasure
having you with us today.
Iain: Thank you very much.
Thank you for asking me.
Brent: Hi, everyone.
That's the end of our discussion with Iain
McGilchrist.
Thanks for watching.
As always, let us know what other topics you'd
like AEI scholars to cover on "Viewpoint."
And, to learn more about how our brains pay
attention to the world, check out the links
in the description below.